we will now begin our journey into the
world of statistics which is really a
way to understand or get our head around
data so statistics is all about data and
as we begin our journey into the world
of this of of statistics we will be
doing a lot of what we can call
descriptive statistics so if we have a
bunch of data and if we want to tell
something about all of that data without
giving them all of the data can we
somehow describe it with a smaller set
of numbers so that's what we're going to
focus on and once we build our toolkit
on the descriptive statistics then we
can start to make inferences about that
data start to make conclusions start to
make a judgments and will start to do a
lot of inferential inferential
statistics make inferences so with that
out of the way let's think about how we
can describe a data so let's say we have
a set of numbers we can consider this to
be data maybe we're measuring the
heights of our plants in our garden and
let's say we have six plants and the
heights are four inches three inches one
inch six inches and another one's one
inch and then another one is seven
inches and let's say someone just said
in another room not looking at your
plants just say well you know how tall
are your plants and they only want to
hear one number they want to somehow
hear get somehow give have one number
that represents all of these different
heights of plants how would you do that
well you'd say well how can I find
something that maybe I want a typical
number maybe I want some number that
somehow represents the middle maybe I
want the most frequent number maybe I
want the number that somehow represents
the center of all of these numbers and
if you said any of those things you
would actually have done the same things
that the people who first came up with
descriptive statistics said they said
well what how can we do it and we'll
start by thinking of the idea of average
average and in every day in every day
terminology average has a very
particular meaning as we'll see when
many people talk about average
going about the arithmetic mean which
we'll see shortly but when we in
statistics average means something more
general it really means give me a
typical give me a typical or give me a
middle
give me a middle number or these are ORS
and really it's an attempt to find a
measure of central tendency central
central tendency tendency so once again
you have a bunch of numbers you're
somehow trying to represent these with
one number we'll call it the average
that somehow typical or middle or the
center somehow of these numbers and as
we'll see there's many types of averages
the first is the one that you're
probably most familiar with it's the one
when people talk about hey the average
on this exam or the average height and
that's the arithmetic mean so let me
write it in I'll write it in yellow
Aerith arithmetic arithmetic mean when
arithmetic is a noun we call it
arithmetic when it's an adjective like
this we call it arithmetic arithmetic
mean and this is this is really just the
sum of all the numbers divided by and
this is a human constructed definition
that we've found useful the sum of all
of these numbers defined divided by the
number of numbers we have so given that
what is the arithmetic mean of this data
set well let's just compute it it's
going to be four plus three plus one
plus six plus one plus seven over over
the number of data points we have
so we have six data points so we're
going to divide by six and we get 4 plus
3 is 7 plus 1 is 8 plus 6 is 14 plus 1
is 15 plus 7 15 plus 7 is 22 we do that
one more time you have 7 8
14 15 22 all of that over 6 and we could
write this as a mixed number 6 goes into
22 three times with the remainder of 4
so it's 3 + 4 6 was the same thing as 3
+ 2 2/3
we could write this as a decimal with
3.6 repeating so this is also 3.6
repeating we could write at any one of
those ways but this is kind of a
representative number this is trying to
get at a central tendency once again
these are human constructed no one ever
it's not like someone just found some
you know religious document that said
this is the way that the arithmetic mean
must be defined it's not as pure of a of
a computation as say finding the
circumference of the circle which there
really is that was kind of we studied
the universe and that just fell out of
our study of the universe it's a human
constructed definition that we found
useful now there are other ways to
measure the average or find a typical or
middle value the other very typical way
is the median and I will write median
I'm running out of colors I will write
meeting in pink so there is the median
and the median is literally looking for
the middle number so if you were order
all the numbers in your set and find the
middle one then that is your median so
given that what's the median of this set
of numbers going to be let's try to
figure it out let's try to order it so
we have one then we have another one
then we have a three then we have a four
a six and a seven so all I did is I
reorder this and so what's the middle
number
well you look here since we have an even
number of numbers we have six numbers
there's no there's not one middle number
you actually have two middle numbers
here you have two middle numbers right
over here you have the three and the
four and in this case when you have two
middle numbers you actually take you
actually go halfway between these two
numbers or essentially you're taking the
arithmetic mean of these two numbers to
find the median so the median is going
to be halfway in between three and four
which is going to be three point five so
the median in this case the median in
this case is three point five so if you
have an even number of numbers the
median over the middle to the
essentially the arithmetic mean of the
middle two or halfway between the middle
two if you have an odd number of numbers
it's a little bit easier to compute and
just so that we see that let me give you
another data set let's say our data set
I'll order it for us let's say our data
set was 0 750
I don't know 10,000 10,000 and 1 million
1 million let's say that that is our
data set kind of a crazy data set but in
this situation what is our median well
here we have five numbers we have an odd
number of numbers so it's easier to pick
out a middle the middle is the number
that is that is greater than two of the
numbers and is less than two of the
numbers it's exactly in the middle so in
this case our median is 50 now the third
measure of central tendency and this is
the one that's probably used least often
in life is the mode and people often
forget about it and it sounds like
something very complex but what we'll
see is it's actually a very
straightforward idea and in some ways it
is the most basic idea so the mode is
actually the most common number in a
data set if there is a most common
number if all the numbers are
represented equally if there's no one
single most common number then you have
no mode but what given that definition
of the mode what is the single most
common number in our original data set
in this data set right over here well we
have only have one four we only have one
three but we have two ones we have one
six and one seven so the number that
shows up the most number of times here
is is our one so the mode the most
typical number the most common number
here is is a one so you see these are
all different ways of trying to get at a
typical or middle or central tendency
but they you do it in very very
different ways and as we study more and
more statistics we'll see that they're
good for different things
this is used very frequently the median
is really good if you have some kind of
crazy number out here that could have
otherwise skewed the arithmetic mean the
mode could also be useful in situations
like that especially if you do have one
number that's showing up a lot more
frequently anyway I'll leave you there
and we'll the next few videos we will
explore statistics Eve
and Eber